clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci à toi
salut romain ça va je suis désolé je
suis un petit peu à la bourre non c'est
pas très sympa comme je t'ai laissé
attendre tout seul hyper sympa bon
recchi qui se souvient de gilbert bécaud
banon bon non plus il a chanté la
solitude ça n'existe pas par exemple
spontanément comme ça on a envie de lui
répondre
désolé mon vieux mais non nulle solitude
ça existe de ouf c'est même le mal du
siècle donc mais en y réfléchissant un
peu la solitude ça veut dire quoi la
solitude donc ce serait le mal du siècle
bon apparemment il ya match quand même
un pour le mal du siècle
donc si ça se trouve le mal du siècle
c'est l'expression mal du siècle en fait
oui bon bref
d'après les derniers sondages sur le
sujet 80 % des françaises et des
français estiment que la solitude c'est
un vrai problème et 44% d'entre eux
disant souffrir au moins de temps en
temps et ce n'est pas que français parce
que la grande bretagne a créé un
ministère de la solitude pour lutter
contre ce fléau et aux etats-unis
pendant la convention annuelle betsy
américain on a estimé que la solitude
était une plus grande menace pour les
américains que l'obésité
c'est quand même pas rien surtout aux
états unis pêle mêle on entend dire que
la solitude donnerait de l'hypertension
artérielle du cholestérol qu'elle
favoriserait la maladie d'alzheimer
qu'elle serait plus mauvaise pour la
santé que 15 cigarettes par jour et
qu'elle pourrait même tuer on a des
nouvelles de britney spears
[Musique]
mal du siècle ou pas la solitude ce
serait donc une maladie une maladie
mortelle même ok mais alors la solitude
c'est quoi et bah gilbert bécaud il
avait peut-être raison
la solitude ça n'existe pas les
solitudes peut-être parce que le mot
enveloppes des situations très
différentes
si on prend la définition littérale la
solitude c'est l'état de quelqu'un qui
est seul momentanément ou habituellement
et si on regarde les exemples choisis
pour illustrer ça ça ressemble pas
exactement au mal du siècle mais ça on
va y revenir
par contre si on regarde la définition
de l' isolement déjà là on commence à
sentir une première nuance entre la
solitude choisie et la solitude subi
c'est à dire isolement
l' isolement ça peut être la conséquence
de situations de la vie très différente
comme la maladie
l'hospitalisation la vieillesse la
prison l'expatriation plein de choses
mais en dehors de ces situations
si ça concerne autant de gens c'est
qu'il ya autre chose on est d'accord
c'est tout chaud c'est d'une part la
perception qu'on a de la solitude et qui
est pas forcément liés aux noms de
personnes dans notre entourage parce
qu'il ya des personnes qui sont très
entourés et qui se sentent très seuls
et c'est vrai que cette espèce de lien
constant qu'on a avec les autres avec
les smartphones les réseaux sociaux etc
ça a un petit peu changé la donne mais
ça ça mériterait une vidéo à part
entière mais en plus de ce sentiment
d'être seul ou pas il ya aussi la façon
dont on perçoit dont on ressent le fait
d'être seul
c'est ce qui fait toute la différence
entre les personnes qui recherchent la
solitude et qu'il apprécie et celles qui
cherchent à tout prix à la fuir parce
qu'elle les fait se sentir mal parce que
pour choisir wentzel bien sûr faut
pouvoir avoir le choix entre lettres ou
pas mais il faut aussi être capable
d'aimer ça de base c'est vrai que pour
un grand nombre de personnes la solitude
elle est perçue de façon négative hier à
côté péjoratif quelqu'un qui mange tout
seul au restaurant par exemple il va
facilement inspiré une espèce de pitié
alors que si ça se trouve il vit sa
meilleure vie mais il ya aussi autre
chose pour décrire cette incapacité à se
sentir bien quand on est seul il ya un
mot l'autophobie alors non c'est pas une
peur panique des jeux de hasard à base
de boules colorées
c'est la peur de se retrouver seul et en
même temps littéralement la peur
soi même ou en tout cas la peur de se
retrouver seul avec soi-même
donc il y aurait en même temps cette
peur du regard des autres cette peur
d'être jugé parce qu'on est seul mais
aussi une peur de se retrouver seul face
à face avec soi même
soit parce qu'on s'aime pas soit parce
qu'on se sent pas capable de remplir ce
vide que la solitude représente pour
nous parce qu'on a jamais appris à le
faire par exemple du cool attitude
classique c'est de tenter de remplir ce
vide par tous les moyens
en recherchant à tout prix la compagnie
des autres avec le risque de les
solliciter tout le temps et de finir par
être rejetés ou de se sentir rejeté
quand ils sont à dispo en comblant ce
vide avec des relations amoureuses en
multipliant les aventures ou en se
mettant en quête absolue d'une relation
de couple avec un gros risque de
dépendance affective parce que dans ces
cas là on n'a plus besoin de l'autre
qu'on en a envie et ça s'est jamais ça
dans les deux cas il ya le même risque
celui de sauter sur toutes les occasions
de pas être seul du coup d'être déçus
parce qu'on se retrouve dans des
situations où des relations qui
correspondent pas à ce qu'on veut
vraiment où est ce qu'on aime vraiment
et de se sentir encore plus seul
et puis autre truc classique se remplir
pour remplir le vide avec de la
nourriture avec de l'alcool avec des
drogues qui en plus tentent d'endormir
l'angoissent spoiler ça crée beaucoup
plus de problèmes que ça non raison donc
en fait cette frénésie de pas être seul
c'est pas courir après quelque chose
c'est courir pour fuir quelque chose ou
plutôt courir pour fuir quelqu'un soit
même et pourtant la solitude c'est
indispensable
c'est hyper important de se retrouver
seul avec soi même pour une petite
introspection ou pour se faire plaisir à
soi même
alors je parle pas seulement de
masturbation alors que même si ce truc
là encore aujourd'hui ça reste un peu
tabou et vu de façon négative
c'est sûrement un peu lié mais surtout
est bien quand on est tout seul c'est
être bien avec soi même et donc quand ce
n'est pas le cas ça vaut le coup de
creuser un peu pour comprendre pourquoi
ne serait-ce que parce que pour être
bien avec les autres faut d'abord être
bien avec soi même quand on y arrive on
choisit
les gens qu'on a envie de voir et les
occasions dans lesquels on a envie de
les voir celles qui nous font envie
n'est pas celle dont on pense avoir
besoin et on donne aussi envie aux
autres de nous voir parce que ces
moments là c'est des moments agréables
c'est des moments riches c'est des
moments où il ya de l'échangé des trucs
à partager on a des trucs à raconter ce
qu'on a fait quand il n'était pas là par
exemple donc savoir est seul c'est
indispensable parce que c'est le seul
moyen de ne pas dépendre des autres pour
être bien et parce que aimé est seul
c'est s'aimer soi même mais c'est aussi
simple alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour apprendre à aimer être seul
la première chose c'est sûrement de
casser cette image négative de la
solitude et la crainte du regard des
autres quand on est seul se répéter ça
pour s'en convaincre
et puis ensuite passer à la pratique en
y allant crescendo se balader en solo à
l'exposer dans un café ou dans un parc
pour poutine est allé au cinéma se faire
un petit plaisir simple tout seul vous
verrez que très clairement les autres
gens ont autre chose à faire que de vous
regarder en se demandant pourquoi vous
êtes tout seul surtout si vous avez
l'air de kiffer ensuite pour essayer de
trouver ce qu'on peut faire pour se
faire du bien prendre soin de soi
prendre soin de son corps se faire un
masque en soins ce qu'on veut se
cuisiner un petit truc à manger qu'on
aime bien
n'importe quoi du moment que c'est une
démarche qui vous procure un plaisir
immédiat et qui n'a aucun autre but que
ça vous mettre bien faire du sport ou
des trucs créatifs genres de la musique
du dessin écrire tout ça ça marche bien
aussi parce que c'est un moment qu'on
passe avec soi qui nous procure du
plaisir qu'on peut refaire régulièrement
avec en plus la satisfaction de voir
qu'on progresse ça ça fait du bien à
l'image qu'on a de soi même et on a vu
que dans ces cas là on en a bien besoin
par pas besoin de se lancer dans des
trucs incroyables surtout il faut pas se
fixer des objectifs trop élevés aux
débuts des petites choses c'est très
bien et si vous savez rien faire de tout
ça est bas à prendre justement ça peut
être une bonne idée parce que ça aussi
c'est hyper valorisant à condition
d'être indulgent avec vous-même et de
penser à vous dire
vaud quand vous arrivez à faire quelque
chose mais évidemment dans l'absolu en
plus de tout ça le mieux c'est aussi
d'aller en parler avec un professionnel
un psy pour comprendre d'où ça vient
cette auto phobies et avoir des pistes
pour que ça s'arrange
ça empêche pas d'avancer de son côté
mais ça aide à aller plus vite et a duré
sur le long terme si vous voulez il ya
aussi des livres et des vidéos hyper
intéressant sur le sujet je vous mets
les liens dans la description de la
vidéo alors attention
apprendre à être seul ça ne veut pas
dire être seul tout le temps pour
réussir à être autonome à se suffire à
soi même par moments a pas dépendre des
autres pour être bien mais l'être humain
c'est un animal social donc l'idée c'est
pas de fuir complètement les autres
garder contact avec vos proches et vos
amis
prenez de leurs nouvelles de temps en
temps ça se fait aussi et puis quand
vous avez envie proposez leur de faire
un truc ensemble
attention proposez-leur un truc dont
vous avez vraiment envie et un truc qui
va leur faire plaisir à eux aussi faut
pas que ce soit juste un moyen de sortir
de votre homme vous verrez ça change
tout donc oui la solitude ça peut rendre
malade quand on est dans une situation
d'isolement
quand elle est subie ou quand on sait
pas la gérer c'est une réalité et en
plus de tous les troubles dont on a
parlé au début de la vidéo ça peut aussi
provoquer des troubles psychologiques et
un manteau voir pousser au suicide donc
c'est un vrai sujet mais la solitude
c'est pas une maladie en soi c'est même
vital et si vous êtes autophobe et que
vous arrivez à l'apprivoiser ça va
devenir votre meilleur ami et vous
changez la voix la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien